hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast genome in a bottle
developing benchmarks for structural
variants presents by Justin Zook
research scientist at ISC I'm Alexis
trials the Blackbirds and I'll be your
moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before you begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on a helpdesk
button located in the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use the ask the question box to let us
know that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and those
offers continuing education credits
please click on a continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
doctors up I will now turn the
presentation over to him
invitation to talk about the work we've
been doing as part of our genome in a
bottle consortium and I'll give a little
bit of background information about the
work we've been doing a genome in a
bottle for all types of variation in a
genome and then we'll focus specifically
on the work we've been doing developing
benchmark call sets for structural
variants which are a more challenging
type of variation in the genome to
assess so the main things that I'll be
talking about today that I'd like to get
out of this is that genome mini bottles
mission is to authoritative we
characterize human genomes and our
current characterization of the genome
enables benchmarking of easier variants
and regions like small variants and
mostly non repetitive regions in
germline genomes and this has really
been used widely in clinical validation
and in technology development and
optimization and demonstration but it
still leaves out a lot of the more
challenging variants and regions of the
genome and so we are now working on more
difficult variants and difficult regions
and in particular I'm going to focus on
our work on larger variants today so
we've made some draft variant calls
greater than 20 base pairs in size
available and have been get collecting
feedback about those calls and are
continuing to collect feedback and now
we're working on finalizing a tiered
benchmark set greater than or equal to
50 base pairs that would also have high
confidence regions that could be used
there are lots of challenges and doing
this and lots of work to do and get
getting to more difficult variants and
regions and this is an open science
project and collaboration they're very
welcome so please let me know if you're
interested in participating in our work
so first why we're doing this work as
part of genome in a bottle and why we
formed the genome in a bottle consortium
so the need is really that to help to
know
whether this your the answer that you
get from sequencing a human genome is
correct and of course when you use
genome sequencing in Diagnostics or
precision medicine this really requires
high levels of confidence and so it's
important to have benchmarks that can be
used and you'll see this figure this
Venn diagram on the right hand side from
several years ago that compared a lot of
different small varying colors on an
exome sequencing data set and only about
60% of the variant calls agreed between
there's five different variant colors
even when using the same underlying
sequencing data and of course this has
improved over time and for the easier
regions of the genome we really get
quite high concordance between the
different methods now especially for
small variants but once you get into
more difficult variants and more
difficult regions there's still a lot of
discordance between different methods
and so the approach we've been taking to
to address this challenge of different
methods disagreeing with each other is
to develop some well characterized
genomes and just a small number of them
to benchmark performance of sequencing
methods so I'd missed one of the things
we do is create reference materials
which are really well characterized
materials in this case it's extracted
human genome DNA from cell lines and we
have five genomes that we've made
available as reference materials from
nist these are also available as both
DNA and as cell lines from the coriolis
align repository and we sequence these
with many different methods and try to
disseminate benchmark variant calls that
can be used in benchmark regions that
can be used to evaluate the senior
sequencing methods performance and we've
also done a lot of work towards
providing benchmarking methods so that
you can compare your calls to ours in a
standardized way and
make sure that you're getting out
accurate and meaningful performance
metrics in the end that you can compare
across experiments so first talking
about sort of what what is genome in a
bottle we are as I mentioned were doing
all for a tative characterization of
human genome and so we're not trying to
characterize lots of different samples
like it's not a population study this is
really a small number of genomes that
were trying to sequence as deeply and
with as many different orthogonal
methods as we can we created the first
human genome reference materials that
were characterized on a genome scale we
have five of them that we've released
now we have an enduring commitment to
resource availability and this includes
both enduring commitment to make these
samples available really broadly as well
as to making the data available and this
is the raw data the analyses that are
done on those data as well as the high
confidence benchmark goals that we make
available we really have put a lot of
emphasis on making these widely
available open resources so that there
are no restrictions on their use or on
distribution that means that we've there
have been a number of commercial
products that actually use these samples
as a basis for their reference samples
that are aimed at more clinical uses and
and there are no restrictions on
publication on these data and so we
really encourage anyone to use these
data as part of their methods
development process because that then
helps us also in characterizing these
genomes we really try to enable
technology development and tool building
by disseminating these benchmark samples
and this has been used in development of
new technologies in optimization of new
technologies and bio informatics methods
and then to demonstrate the performance
of these these methods when they're
released the germline samples that we've
been developing are available now and
will likely continue to develop some
additional germline samples and then
we're also developing capacity for
cancer samples or somatic samples but
this is a longer-term work and we don't
yet have any samples that are available
for that that said there has been some
work that's been done on mixing together
our your mine samples to sort of
simulate somatic mutations and that can
be useful as one of the things that you
do as part of understanding the
performance of somatic variant calling
so genome in a bottle has sort of
evolved from when it first started in
2012 where we're really there were no
human benchmark calls available so we
formed this genome in a model consortium
this consortium includes
people developing sequencing
technologies people from other
government institutes and a lot of
bioinformatics developers both those
kind of academic labs as well as
companies and also people developing
reference samples and clinical
laboratories in 2014 we released our
first we published our first small
variant genotypes which covered about
77% of the genome in our pilot genome
which is the well-known sample na12878
from Coryell in 2015 we released that as
a human genome reference material from
NIST which was the first reference
material characterized on a genome scale
in 2016 we characterized four more
genomes from the Personal Genome Project
and we released new small variant calls
that covered now about 90% of these five
genomes and it also we made calls for
birth grch37 ng or CH 38 so you could
benchmark on either of these references
and then for the past couple years and
going forward we're
we're really focusing on characterizing
difficult variants and difficult regions
of the genome for these germline genomes
as well as developing tumor samples and
then developing methods to characterize
these tumor samples so we've
characterized five human genomes so far
that we've released as missed reference
materials the pilot genome is this
na12878 sample the and then the other
genomes that we've characterized are
from the personal genome project and
we've done this because it enables
commercial products to be developed from
them and they're really broadly
consented so that there are a lot of
different uses that can can be applied
to these genomes and you could I now
have a slide about this later about some
of the different uses that people I've
already had for them and there are many
others that we have but people will come
up with in the future so we have an
Ashkenazi Jewish trio that's a mother
father-son trio and a son in a Chinese
trio where we are also characterizing
the the parents in the trio but they're
not released as reference materials that
are only available from Coryell we've
chosen to work with to characterize
trios like this because that can help us
in in both understanding the accuracy of
our variant calls by seeing whether
variants and genotypes are inherited as
we'd expect them to be and it also helps
with things like phasing and and some
methods can even take advantage of this
trio information to come to better
characterize the genomes so we have
released all of our data openly as as
quickly as we can and we've also tried
to describe these data as low as we can
so that that anyone can use these one of
the ways that we described data in 26
the data that we collected up through
2016 of
through a publication and nature journal
scientific data which allows you to
publish publish datasets without doing
extensive analyses on them yet and so
this allows anyone in the community to
know what data is available and how they
can use these data as part of their
their pipelines this was a really big
effort where that included many
different authors and institutions there
were 12 different types of data that
were published in this sum from short
reads to linked reads to long reads to
optical mapping methods and it was data
from seven different genomes and the
data were described in detail so that
that anyone can can use these we've made
these data openly available and all of
our analyses are friendly available
because this has resulted in sort of
virtual open science press so the cycle
that that sort of we continually go
through is that users can analyze the
genome in a bottle samples either
getting the DNA or cells and sequencing
with a new method or taking the data
we've already made available and
analyzing that data with new methods and
they can use that for method development
for optimization and demonstration by
benchmarking the results that they get
versus our genome in a bottle benchmark
datasets this could be part of their
asset validation process if for example
it's a clinical laboratory that's doing
this and then the other thing that we
ask everyone to do is give us feedback
about the calls that we've made
available so that so that we know
whether there are any weaknesses in our
current benchmark datasets that we could
help to address by incorporating in the
new methods that people are developing
so if it looks like any of these new
methods that were developed are going to
be useful for
improving our high confidence calls or
for expanding to more difficult regions
and we're difficult variants well
integrate those new methods into our
integration process release new
benchmark datasets and then users can
again compare to these and we'll go
through the cycle again over and over
again - to iteratively improve and this
is really important in the in genome
sequencing because the technologies and
the methods are evolving so rapidly and
so it's important for us to to basically
make sure that our benchmark datasets
stay ahead of these new methods or keep
up with the new methods so that anyone
can benchmark the new methods and know
how well they're doing for more
difficult regions and we're for more
difficult periods in the genome the
other thing this Open have been science
enables is secondary reference samples
there are now more than thirty products
that are available from several
different institutions that are based on
these broadly consented well
characterized genome in a bottle cell
lines from the Personal Genome Project
so we've been really grateful to work
with a Personal Genome Project in this
and and grateful to the individuals
contributing these samples to the
Personal Genome Project because they
enable a lot of innovative products and
these products so far have included
things like the genomic DNA from our
cell lines plus synthetic DNA spike ends
and these synthetic DNA fragments have
might have clinical variants in them of
interest since our cell lines don't
necessarily have particular clinically
interesting variants in them they've
also had variants spiked in at different
allele frequencies to mimic somatic
variation and then there's also a
product that we've helped to
characterize that has difficult variants
in it so these are difficult variants in
clinically targeted regions so that
clinical laboratories can assess how
well they're characterizing these more
difficult variants and clinically
interesting regions and and this is
really important because the the
variants in our cell lines tend to be
mostly snips in clinically targeted
regions and so if you're doing a
targeted panel you also really need to
have other types of more difficult
variants that you can understand your
performance of and and this type of
sample helps with that there's also work
been done to put these cells in matrix
that would mimics what clinical samples
would look like so for example in
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded the
samples there are some that are being
developed to mimic circulating tumor DNA
there are now stem cells available from
Coryell and there may be more of these
developed in the future and then in the
future there are some groups that are
looking at editing these genomes where
you might be able to edit in particular
variants of of interest for benchmarking
so the approach that we've taken to
develop high confidence variant calls
for our genomes is to integrate a
diverse array of data types and a
diverse set of different analysis
methods to be characterize our genomes
and so we have a lot of data that we've
made publicly available and we both
characterize these data ourselves but a
lot of the work has been done by the
community the genome and a model
community too to apply new methods to to
all of these data that we've made
available so we have deep short green
sequencing linked read sequencing like
that from 10x genomics long reads like
there's from PacBio and from Oxford
nanopore and then optical and nanopore
mapping data like that from my own a no
genomic synapses and then we have a lot
of different analysis methods so we have
released benchmark calls based on small
variant calling methods
and we're now working on structural
variant Colleen and and also
incorporating in results from local and
global assembly methods and this is
another sort of cycle that we go through
where we try to discover and refine
sequence resolved calls from multiple
data sets and analyses by sequence
resolved here I mean that we think we
know what the actual sequence changes as
opposed to sort of just knowing that
roughly some region of the genome might
be duplicated or deleted we compare the
different methods variant calls to each
other and their genotype calls to each
other
we evaluate those calls using all of the
different data sets that we have we try
to identify features associated with the
reliability of the calls from each of
the methods so and these might be things
like mapping quality for that particular
data sets at that location or strand
bias or base quality scores or clipping
of the reads or a number of these
different features that are often output
by varying colors and then we use these
features to understand when we can trust
each method and so if they disagree with
each other we we trust ones that sort of
look like good normal calls and we form
our benchmark calls using mostly
heuristics up to this point with a
little bit of machine learning and we're
exploring more sophisticated machine
learning methods to integrate all these
data together and then to evaluate the
benchmark calls that we get we compare
these to other high quality call sets
that you might want to benchmark here
that gets these calls and then manually
curate any differences between other
call sets in our benchmark and our goal
in the end is to resolving calls where
if you compare to our benchmark calls
the majority of putative false-positives
and false-negatives are actually errors
in your data sets rather than
in our benchmarking call sad or errors
in like the comparison process so our
small variant calls have undergone an
evolution from what we published back in
2014 which was version 2.1 9/2 the calls
that we published last year in version
3.3 plane
to where initially we'd covered about 77
percent of the genome now we cover about
90 percent of the genome the number of
variant calls has increased pretty
substantially and number of indels is
also increased substantially over time
we one of the ways we've evaluated our
calls was by comparing two platinum
genomes which I've abbreviated PGE and
in these slides and the number of
differences between these call sets has
decreased since our initial call sets
and when we go in and actually look at
these differences we find that a pretty
small number of the differences or
actually errors in the missed high
confidence calls and so we really
roughly estimate that maybe there are
about two false positives and false
negatives per million missed variants
that are inside our high confidence
regions and also inside the Platinum
genome site confidence regions and we
can't really assess the performance of
our calls outside the platinum genomes
high confidence regions so it's a little
hard to know exactly what the errors are
error rates are but we talked about this
in some more detail including some
evaluations we did based on trio
Mendelian inheritance in this preprint
that's linked to at the bottom left of
this slide the other thing we've added
to our calls over time is phasing
information and this is mostly based on
using the pedigree that that any one two
eight seven eight is part of or the
trios that the other samples are part of
and we haven't done a lot of evaluations
of these phasing yet but so
we're now working on trying to
incorporate some of the newer phasing
methods and using things like linked
reeds and and other new phasing methods
to to to add additional phasing
information and additional confidence to
that phasing the other thing that's been
really important is to develop
benchmarking tools that anyone can use
to compare to our high confidence calls
and so you might think that this is sort
of straightforward thing to do where you
just like take your variant call listing
empirical are very in call list and and
you can just say how many are the same
and how many are different and that
gives you the performance metrics as an
output but there are a lot of
complications when you get into the
details of this and I one of the initial
things that we did as part of this
global line make some health
benchmarking team is develop
standardized definitions for performance
metrics like true positive and false
positive and false negative and the way
we chose to do this is to define
different levels of stringency when
you're doing the matching and so in some
applications you might want to make sure
that your variant calls and your
genotype calls are correct and then we
only counted as a true positive if both
of those are correct and that's actually
the default matching that we we use with
our tools but we also have put other
statistics that allow you to see how
many of those errors are genotyping
errors or how many of those are places
where you there is actually a very
Intune that region and you're just
calling the wrong variants in that
region the other thing we've developed
as part of this team is sophisticated
benchmarking toolkits that that sort of
is integrated into a single framework
that has standardized inputs and outputs
and there were a number of different
sophisticated benchmarking and varying
comparison tools that were developed to
handle cases like the complex variant
that's delineate it on the right-hand
side here and so one of the challenges
when doing
comparisons is that variance can be
represented in different ways and some
of the hardest cases are cases like
these complex variants where you have a
set of bases that's replaced by a
different different set of bases and
that could be represented just as a
single very inch like it is on the top
or it can be represented as in this case
deletion and a snit as it is on the
bottom on the right inside and there
would actually be even more ways of
representing this variant and there's
not really a clear way to standardize
representation in all of these cases or
to normalize these representations all
these cases normalization can help but
it tends to not really resolve all of
the different challenging representation
cases that occur in the genome because a
lot of these occur in repetitive regions
and there are and and there are enough
of these complex very into the genome
that they end up contributing pretty
significantly to your false positives
and false negatives if you don't do use
a sophisticated benchmarking tool then
finally what we've done is developed
standardized bed files that allow you to
stratify your performance by genome
context and so it allows you to see how
well you do for but for your variants in
easy non repetitive regions of the
genome versus different types of
repetitive regions of the genome whether
these are different like so promo
polymers are different lengths of tandem
repeats or difficult to map regions of
the genome and and this allows you to
know sort of where you might might need
to improve your methods or where the
weaknesses in your methods are and we've
made these of these tools available on
github they're also described in a lot
of detail and with some examples in a
preprint that's linked to here on the in
the bottom left-hand side of the slide
the other thing we've done is make these
work with the precision fda team to make
these tools available in the precision
FD
a interface and this is a nice web-based
interface to our benchmarking tools that
allows you to simply upload your variant
call file select which genome it's from
and so which benchmark VCF and bed file
you want to compare to and and and then
will output the the performance metrics
in a strand standardized way and it will
output all these stratifications that
I've mentioned and this was also our
tools and our benchmark call sets were
also used as part of a couple challenges
that the precision FDA hosted that that
where the community could contribute
analyses of our genomes and and so
anyone can see sort of how these methods
compare to our call sets and and how
they perform in these different genome
contexts and and you can go to the
precision FDA site and anyone can apply
for an account there and and you these
results as low as do your own
comparisons and either make them public
or not as you choose so we've done a lot
of work on small variants but there is
still a lot of the genome that's
challenging to to address and I've at
least sort of roughly tried to estimate
sort of what we're still missing in the
genome and visit this is not a like
really precise quantitative estimate
those of what we're missing but just to
give a sense it for simple snips and non
repetitive regions were probably calling
about 97% of the variants and in our
high country
and we're we're covering about 90% of
that 7% of them in our high confidence
regions so we might have about a hundred
thousand or so variants that we're still
missing and this this region and and
then there are also simple in Dells and
non repetitive regions that and we're
maybe missing about seven percent of
those but I'm worried we're missing a
much larger percentage of very
once you get two little map ability
regions once you get to reap and of
course regions that aren't even in
grch37 orgy or grch38 we're not
characterizing that all at this point
there are small n bells that are in
tandem repeats and homopolymers that
we're not yet accessing we're
characterizing probably less than 50% of
these right now and so there are many
more that we have yet to characterize
and then as you get to larger indels and
structural variants were we're missing
many of these in our current
characterization and so a lot of our
work right at the moment is focused on
these we have also started work on
difficult to map regions and tandem
repeats and homopolymers we're
interested in extending our approach to
the purchase that we've used so far two
structural variants and there are a lot
of similarities to what we've done for
small variants where we can collect call
sets from multiple different
technologies and multiple different
calling methods we can compare these
call sets to each other to find calls
that are supported by by multiple
technologies but there are a lot of
challenges that we've had to address
that are different from small variants
so for small variants call sets tend to
have pretty high sensitivity to variance
if you set the parameters correctly at
least in defined regions of the genome
well that aren't difficult to map or
repetitive but for structural variants
that's not always the case yet variants
are also often and precisely
characterized so there there might not
be exact right point sorry the exact
size or type or sequence that's
predicted for insertions the
representation of these variants is
poorly standardized and that's
especially true once you get to more
complex changes that occur in repetitive
regions and then tools to do the
comparisons of structural variants are
really in their infancy and so there
i've been a there's been a lot of work
that's been done in this in the past
couple years but we have yet to
sort of come to a consensus on what's
the best approaches to do this yet so
our integration strategy for structural
reigns has been to collect as to collect
many different candidate calls for our
Ashkenazi Jewish trio from the Personal
Genome Project we've collected it our
calls from many different technologies
from short reads and linked reads and
long reads and from optical or nano for
base mapping methods and then from many
different calling approaches including
small variant color structural ring
colors and methods that use local or
global de novo assemblies so we got over
a million different calls from over 30
different methods and over five
different technologies then of course
many of these were either exactly the
same or similar to each other and so the
the next step was to sort of revise it
we find and evaluate in genotype these
candidate calls so we're one of the
first things we did was try ask for
sequence resolved calls as often as we
could
meaning we want to sort of get the as
close to exact breakpoints and as close
to the exact sequence that's inserted or
deleted as we can and this allows us to
use sort of a uniform message to any
great piece call sets together and
allows us to output calls that are
easier to use as a benchmark set since
we've more precisely defined what
exactly we think the sequence change is
now and so this is often done using
assembly based approaches either local
or global assembly based approaches once
we have these sequence resolved calls we
compare the sequence predictions of the
candidate calls and merge calls that are
sufficiently similar to each other and
then we go back and if the calls look
like they have enough support that we
want to evaluate them further we
determine the supports in the raw data
for each of these sequence resolved
calls and we try to genotype them based
on that that data and we've been using a
tool called s weave is to do that
genotyping
so we've gone through multiple
iterations of integrating calls using
sort of an evolving set of methods where
initially we were just using deletions
and we didn't have sequence resolved
calls then we moved to using sequence
resolved calls in version 0.3 and we did
clustering based on that and version 0.4
we used s we've is to evaluate the calls
as well as using the optical mapping and
nanopore based mapping methods we also
added genotypes for all three members of
the trio in this case and then in our
current latest call step version 0.5 we
used some new calling methods that were
developed especially to help to call
larger insertions in a sequence resolved
way and we also included more calls that
were only called my single technology
because we found that some of these look
like they were likely to be true but but
we evaluated them too with the raw data
to make sure that they were supported
and we added some preliminary phasing
information though this is still a work
in progress and the work that we're
currently undergoing and will continue
to work on in the future is to resolve
some cases where we have clusters of
differing calls because that we find
that so in some cases these are actually
have two different calls on the two
different alleles or you might have two
calls that are near by each other on the
same allele but there are a lot of other
cases where there's one correct call and
one incorrect call at the same location
and we're we're still trying to work on
ways to resolve resolve these cases one
of the ways we're working on that is by
improving phasing information that we
have we're also adding in new data types
and improving the sequence resolution of
the calls and then we're also working on
developing high confidence regions so
that you can look at both false positive
and false negative rates for your cause
the the set of evaluation
genotyping methods that we've used up to
this point has been primarily using sv
vis which Maps reads to the reference
and alternates alleles that are
hypothesized and sees which which allele
the reads support better and we've done
this with backfire means we've also
phased the pack by reads using 10x and
actual code what's hat
so that we could see whether the support
for heterozygous calls segregates by
allele or by haplotype and we've also
used the women appeared and and mate
pair data as well as 10x data that's
been kept low type separated and then
we've also compared the sizes that pyro
Nano predicts and that abscess predicts
to our cause to to enable us to assess
the accuracy of larger insertions and
deletions in the future we're continuing
to work on better separating haplotypes
for our data sets and doing that in and
I'm adding an additional phasing
information from the trio as well we're
working on manual curation of these
these calls and I'll have a slide later
about with a link to a beta version of
this and that starting on around May 8
or so at the biology of genomes
conference will hopefully have this have
a large set of calls that's made
available and be great to have anyone
participates in in that um curation
we're also working on methods for doing
targeted sequencing of these calls to it
to evaluate them using for example PCR
amplification and then Sanger sequencing
and if anyone is interested in helping
with this we're also really open to
collaborations for that we just as some
preliminary analyses for version 0.5 we
we've made some size histograms where we
show smaller calls over here between 50
and thousand base pairs on
left hand side for deletions and
insertions and then larger calls on the
right hand side up to ten thousand base
pairs that we do have calls that are
larger than that also and on the left
hand side you can see a nice peak for a
low insertions around at and deletions
around 300 base pairs in size on the
right hand side you can see a nice peak
around six thousand base pairs for line
insertions and deletions this at least
helps us to they have more confidence
that we're calling some real things that
we'd expect biologically moving forward
beyond the versions here playing five
calls such one of the things we realized
as the genome in a bottle community
tried to compare to these version 0.5
calls is that would probably be useful
to to work on a two-tiered system of
calls where the tier one calls would be
simple calls that are isolated where
we've been able to sequence resolve them
so these would be an insertion or
deletion that's not me or any other
insertions or deletions that that are
large and where we've been able to
sequence resolve them so we think we
know approximately what the sequence
changes and so this is probably building
going to build on our version 0.5 call
set we're probably going to focus on
calls greater than forty nine base pairs
in size even though we've made call
smaller than that and focusing initially
on hg 0 0 2 which is lisanna mark
Ashkenazi trio and we and so we sort of
used a set of heuristics to say that
they had to have sufficient support from
different technologies or multiple call
sets and that they needed to be
supported by ASP viz analyses or by or
by the optical or non upper base mapping
methods they also in this case we
excluded a lot of calls that were within
a thousand base pairs of another greater
than forty nine base pair call and it
turns out that the
something like a third of the calls were
within a thousand base pairs of another
putative call that looked like it was
well supported
so this excluded a significant number
but now we're down to about fourteen
thousand calls that we think are
isolated so that you should can use them
in a better way for benchmarking your
call sets but we didn't want to stick
with only this Tier one call set because
it excludes a lot of these more
difficult variants that that we have
been working on characterizing and and
it's often useful to know whether you
are missing these calls where where
maybe we're pretty confident that there
is a structural variant but it's complex
where we have multiple clustered calls
or where we couldn't come up with a
consensus sequence change at that
location and and so in this case we we
merged calls without requiring that
their sequences were similar to each
other and and are coming up with a set
of this case about twenty six hundred
regions where there were clustered calls
and then we also clustered calls that
were not tested so that they weren't
supported by two two or more
technologies or form or call sets in our
initial clustering and found that still
there were about 9,000 regions that were
multiple technologies or many call sets
supported they call in that region they
just didn't agree on what that call
should be so this tier two call set
would be useful for maybe assessing your
sensitivity to to more difficult calls
but we wouldn't be able to test sort of
how accurate your call is or maybe or
whether you're calling the exact rate
change at that location where the other
thing we we wanted to do in addition to
developing this two-tiered call set is
develop a high confidence med file that
allows you to assess false positive
rates and so to do this we have been
working on a method where we're using
assemblies to to develop this ved file
so we we first start calling variants
from each assembly and
exclude regions around any well
supported variants from these assemblies
that are not in our version 0.5 concept
and then we find regions for each
assembly that are covered by one contig
if it's a haploid assembly or my two
condoms if it's the diploid assembly and
well we're still working on developing
the heuristics that will mean to set
thresholds of sort of how much support
do we need to make this a high
confidence region where we're pretty
sure that we're calling all of the
variants in that region were and so
we're hoping to have this have an
initial version of this here in the next
few weeks and and if you're interested
in sort of engaging in this you can sign
up for our genome in a bottle analysis
team email list and I'll have a link to
that at the end of this presentation so
in addition to developing heuristics and
integration approaches we we also wanted
to develop ways for us to manually
curate these sites because we found that
often it's really useful to actually
look at the raw data in these regions to
understand the support for the variants
and so postdoc in our group heads missed
leslie Chapman has been working on that
these developing a web-based manual
curation tool that allows you to see
visualizations of data like that from IG
b & IG b from PacBio and 10x and women
and other datasets and then also you can
you view the results from SB vis and dot
plots for this region and we're we'd
like to collect Jim put feedback from
from as many people as possible in the
community about whether people think
we're calling the correct variant at
this location what the genotype of the
variant is and how much confidence you
have in that or or whether this is a
more complex region and we're in beta
testing now and so you can go to the
link
in the bottom left and you can sort of
play around with it now but we're not
yet really collecting feedback other
than feedback about the actual interface
to help us improve it but we're planning
to launch this around May 8 or so so
very soon and and volunteers are really
needed to to help us to manually curate
these sites and encourage you to
participate in this so there are a
number of challenges that remain
including getting to larger sequence
resolved insertions we've made a lot of
progress on this but we're so that we
now have more similar numbers between
large insertions and deletions that
still have some work to do for larger
insertions there are a lot of these
dense or clustered calls that that are
different from each other where we stop
to figure out on how to resolve them and
where we and we need to resolve places
where we might have an inner accurate
sequence change or an incomplete
sequence change we're working on
developing bed files to define
homozygous reference regions and then
we're work we're also working on
benchmarking tool development because
there's a lot of needed to understand
how you can pair your varying calls to
ours and understand and then
understanding what performance our
metrics are important for different
applications there is a neutral that's
really just been made public by spiral
genetics that's still like in beta
testing at this point but but it looks
like it'll it incorporates a lot of the
work that we've been doing in genome in
a model so far in different ways of
comparing structural variants and
encourage you to take a look at this if
you're interested also wanted to let you
know that we're developing new datasets
we have new data from 10x genomics
available we're developing PacBio data
from the sequel instrument on the
Chinese trio that as well as additional
data on the ashkenazi trio that's
currently undergoing QC and so should be
made available very soon
we have will have new bio nano data from
their DLS labeling method available very
soon there's a new link to read method
from Complete Genomics that we're making
available soon and then we're also in
collaboration with University of
Birmingham and Nottingham in the UK
we're working on developing ultra long
reads from Oxford nanopore we're
preliminarily getting really like really
long reads like 80 to 90 KB and 50
probably at lower coverage across the
trio than our other data sets but still
likely to be really useful for resolving
some of these complex regions and then
we're also looking into potentially
getting strand seek data which can help
with phasing and inversion detection and
then we're also looking at new samples
and this includes samples from
additional ancestries as well as
developing cancer samples that will
characterize in the future so the road
ahead is sort of characterizing large
variants and difficult small variants
and phasing in the next year and and
probably going forward then in 2019
characterizing more difficult larger
variants and even more difficult small
variants as well as starting with
somatic sample development and new
germline samples and then longer-term
looking at things like diploid assembly
and how do you use those as part of our
variant calling process as well as how
do you benchmark them looking at somatic
variation segmental duplications and
centromere and telomere that there's a
lot of work to do in characterizing
difficult regions of the genome yet so
just wanted you to sort of take home
that that we've been working on
authoritative lis characterizing these
human genomes and really encourage you
to use our data and use our analyses of
these data and and give us feedback on
them but we we currently allow you to
benchmark easier regions and are
actively working on more difficult
regions we're also actively working on
making new new datasets available and so
if you're developing methods it would be
great to have you try out these your
message
amazing and share your analyses with us
so we hope that these will help with
clinical applications and enabling
precision medicine to reach its promise
as well as many research applications in
understanding how new methods are
measuring difficult variants and regions
I'd like to acknowledge that this is the
work of a large number of people both
that NIST as well as in the genome in a
bottle consortium and the Global
Alliance for genomics and health
benchmarking team as well as support and
collaboration from the FDA so finally if
you're interested in additional
information there are a number of links
here on this last slide and happy to
receive any questions or feedback by
email or as part of this webinar as well
and our next public workshop is
scheduled for January 2019 tentatively
probably in at Stanford University in
California so thanks much for your
attention and I'm happy to take any
questions now thank you dr. Zook for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the on the
screen and click the send button lots
are as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started
our first question is beyond structural
variance what are other challenging
regions and variant types that genome in
a bottle plastic characterize yeah so
we've currently been focusing a lot of
our work on structural variation and and
trying to develop a benchmark set for
that but we have started a number of
discussions with groups that are looking
at things like characterizing variants
and difficult to map regions using the
link trees
or using long read the information and
using phasing information and so so
there are a number of methods under
active development from several
different groups that that show a lot of
promise in in characterizing these
regions and so so we're we're working
line on how we can image with these
groups on how we can integrate those the
results from those methods into our high
confidence calls so that anyone can
benchmark their calls in these difficult
to map regions and sort of similarly
we're looking at integrating phasing
information using some of these same
methods and then also calls in tandem
repeats and homopolymers we're right now
where we're not yet fully characterizing
these and a number of people have been
working on developing methods targeted
to lose these regions that we hope to
incorporate within the next couple years
our next question is can anyone
participate in the manual curation of s
bees for genome in a bottle yeah so we
definitely are happy to have anyone
participate in this regardless of your
expertise level and so well we plan to
have some sort of training that you can
go through or some example sites that
you can can look through to understand
how best you can understand the
different types of visualizations that
we give in this web-based staff and and
it'll be great to have have anyone and
of course it's great to have experts
participating in this if you're if
you've already have a lot of experience
looking at these structural variants but
we we hope that we in some initial work
that we did it looked like even even if
you're not an expert you're likely able
to give us useful feedback about many of
these sites to help us to understand
their accuracy doctors are how do you
expect new methods using long and ultra
long reads to be useful
and defining benchmark calls yeah so
we've definitely already been finding
these to be really useful in
characterizing structural variation and
so in particular when we're trying to
characterize this structural variation
in long repetitive regions or or in
regions or in places where there are
large insertions it's been really useful
to have long read information and we're
really excited about getting the even
longer reads that that we're working on
because we expect this will help us to
continue you to get characterizing
longer repeats and and longer insertions
with more confidence but and then these
are also really useful for phasing and
variants and for and it looks like
they're going to be really useful for
characterizing variants in difficult to
map regions as well though that's sort
of an ongoing process since these reads
do have a higher error rate in general
and so characterizing small variants
with them is is taking a substantial
amount of methods development to to use
them in that way and it looks like we
have time for one more question do you
have plans to use new graph gino methods
and do you foresee any challenges with
benchmarking benchmarking these methods
yeah so we've definitely been talking
with the people who are developing these
methods using graph genomes and so for
those who might not be familiar with
them and you can there are methods being
developed where you can incorporate
known variation in the population into a
grass-based reference so you don't just
have a linear reference anymore but it's
now a graph that has multiple potential
paths in it for the different variants
that have been found previously and then
you align the reads to this graph so
that it particularly can help in regions
where where there are larger variants or
where where there's a lot of diversity
and the human population so so it can
help with characterizing structural
variation
it can also help with characterizing
regions like the MHC where there are
where there's a lot of diversity and
different peoples haplotypes are quite
different from the reference and so
we're excited about using these methods
as as part of our integration process in
the future as these methods continue to
be developed and then the other
challenge related to benchmarking these
methods is that that potentially the you
could imagine the graph incorporating
all of the variants that we found in our
samples into the graph and so when
you're benchmarking versus our samples
and use these variants in your graph
you're sort of incorporating prior
knowledge about our samples into your
analysis and so it's possible that these
methods might perform better on our
genome in a bottle samples within they
would on some new sample that has new
variants that haven't yet been
discovered and so I one of those things
these the people developing these graph
genomes are really thinking about as
they develop visas is how you benchmark
them in a way such that such that you
you don't bias your results and so it
might include like making sure they
don't include some of all the variants
that that are found in our samples in
their graph or or doing some other types
of analyses but but I I imagine that
methods like these graph genomes as well
as methods that use like machine
learning like the deep learning based
based methods that have recently been
developed that there needs to be a
special care or taken to not over train
do our samples that we're already making
available and what hopefully by having
additional samples like we've been
making available will help with with
doing that better I would like to once
again think doctors are for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab birds for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for
the man viewing through August of 2018
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye